[Applause]
so are we going to talk about chappelle
special or what we were talking about
this before and it is uh a tricky one
and i know i'm going to seem like a
complete hypocrite because i guess i've
been quite critical of past ones but
i i for whatever reason maybe i'm
growing i'm becoming a better person or
something like that but i do feel
difficult uh difficulty in um
being critical of a stand-up's
work when they're doing stand-up yeah
if you're a stand-up that is
moonlighting as a late night tv host and
you're putting out corny [ __ ] it's like
okay that's not it but if it is your art
and that is your thing i understand the
vulnerability of putting something out
and having the world be able to
criticize it
that is a vulnerable thing yeah
i'm sure
musicians feel this way when they put it
out i'm not a [ __ ] musician so i
don't really care as much about the
thing but i do care a lot about standup
yeah so
it's tricky to come out here and be like
oh let's criticize yeah you know the
greatest working comedian right
um
so
i want to start out with like some
praise
for it
uh i think he is and i've said this on
the podcast before the greatest
storyteller that i've ever seen in my
entire life yeah it's [ __ ]
unbelievable the story at the end if
you're watching the special and then you
maybe you don't like it or something
like that and you're halfway through you
turn off you're missing out on the
greatest part of the special in my
opinion which is the final story that he
tells unbelievable it's probably 10
minutes maybe even more like and it is
masterful like playing with energy like
using comedy as a tool to drive the
story it's really it's really genius
almost like stand-up is just this tool
he has in the shed right and he's
choosing to use it during the
storytelling right when he needs to to
keep pushing the story on you know i
always think about like remember those
like crews in usa the race car game yeah
you got to pass the checkpoint to get a
little more time right like using
the jokes as that past the checkpoints
you can drive this story that we're
really curious to hear like what happens
yeah it's a [ __ ] beautiful story
and not only is it beautiful it's like
strategic and like pointed and really
executes the exact thing that he's
trying to say throughout the special it
was masterful right
uh i mean i thought it was absolutely
brilliant what did you guys think about
at least that section that was
incredible i do wish he ended it right
like 90 seconds earlier the special we
ended it 90 seconds earlier i thought it
would have been [ __ ] perfect on the
line that says yes yeah i mean we're
going to give it up we're going to
assume everybody's seen it by now and if
you haven't seen it it's okay you'll
still enjoy but on the line that's like
uh and i want to have that conversation
with him i knew your father and he was a
great woman
i mean that is that's the perfect baby
i mean it would have been the [ __ ]
like his emmett till ending in
equanimity when he told the emmett till
story was incredible yeah yeah yeah this
would have been even better yeah i wish
he ended it right there it's still so
good good but i wish he ended it right
there yeah and i guess maybe he had
another point that he wants to drive
home yeah like
i'm doing this for my people or
something like that i don't you know but
like
as a pure
storytelling finale that is the final
point [ __ ] perfect maybe he felt he
had to round out the whole piece yeah to
add more but like for me yeah that's the
metaphor for the whole piece yes i could
love you even though maybe you and i
disagree on some [ __ ] and i'm still
gonna say some jokes and they're still
gonna be funny yes even though i really
[ __ ] with you yes that'd be hilarious
if he did not set up that fun for the
kid
like
that i wouldn't respect you
yeah
this kid is just tweeting like where's
his phone
i'm 21 dave where you at
this is good okay um your guys thoughts
on the final story um just off that
point i agree with you i wish you did my
trap right there but i understand
why he included that last thing because
what do you think i just kind of feel
in his head he is
really taking some shots like he feels
like he's taking some i think i'm
assuming i think he's taking like oh i'm
taking some career ending possible shots
like i'm really going at um
the trans i'm really going at jews he's
like hey
i need to let you people know like i
gotta explain it to you the reason why
it is
yeah this is it
i think if you couldn't see the humanity
of dave in that story in and of itself
you're the problem yes people are
dominant i'm sure there's some i also he
gave you two endings yes he gave you the
smart artistic ending and then he gave
you you checked
twitter
yeah yeah yeah yeah like if you didn't
get that i'm gonna make this very easy
for you to get right the fun thing about
art is you leave it open to
interpretation but that's an issue the
issue with cancellation is that it's
open to interpretation yeah what do you
really mean by it yeah can we let him
live or do we [ __ ] kill him okay what
were your thoughts on this just the
story i didn't see the whole thing but i
saw this i saw the story live when we
were in austin yes so you can't speak on
that yeah but so and it was cool i
really enjoyed it and like i actually
was like misdirected by the ending yeah
like i didn't actually see how it was
gonna go and it seemed sort of like a
return to form for him based off of like
his previous specials yeah and i guess
like his set in general that night and
it was a lot more polished than the
night that we'd see
what i was saying
so i was like i'm happy to see that he's
taking that turn and i'm pretty sure
this is his last special with netflix
right uh for a while for like his last
of like the deal yeah i thought he only
had to do like three for the deal i'm
sure he got more on that and then he
re-upped again maybe i'm sure you guys
but yeah i think he can keep re-upping
whenever he wants it's not like um
no he said no he said for a while he
said that
and then he also said uh i'm not talking
about you guys anymore yeah i'm trying
to communicate never talking about the
community and like
and that was after which i wish you also
just leave it like you just left it so
beautifully but my one push back on the
kind of um covering his own ass
who who you can't cancel dave chappelle
he doesn't want to be in your movies
he
is his stand-up will always be worth 40
million dollars a pop he's worth nine
figures he has chappelle show that he
owns now and he can get the [ __ ]
whatever residuals whatever it's called
for forever yeah so he you can't cancel
dave chappelle he doesn't need your new
opportunities but he wants to drink in
bars in michigan without being bothered
so
he has a problem uh drinking in bars in
general i think so i think one of his
friends needs to talk to him
i'm just saying every person can be
cancelled depending on how you look at
cancellation like say if he actually
does want to put out a special event and
say he gets
so much pushback from the jewish
community and the
trans community transporter lgbt
whatever yeah i think
okay so akash is speaking more towards
cancellation in terms of opportunity
financial industry
and you and him probably have different
perspectives you that's enough money but
you can't decide how much uh is enough
money to someone else he may believe
that he wants to make 500 million
dollars and donate 200 [ __ ] a million to
uh the dead poet society for whatever
yes but just just to just to finish the
point so and he's allowed to have that
feeling as well even though that's
enough money for you and maybe when you
get there you'll decide i'd like some
more money too and i want to continue
this i think it's true
i think it's not about money i think
it's about uh lifestyle and i think
he is a comedian he
cares about what people think of you yes
it is very important
as we all do right like if we knew who
we were and we felt validated every
single day we wouldn't go up in front of
strangers and try to tell them to
validate us through laughter right like
so
i think it is painful i'd imagine is
painful for someone who cares about what
people think of him to think of him as
something that he does not identify as
so if he's walking around all day going
these people think i hate gays they
think i'm homophobic they think i'm
transphobic that's probably way more
painful than not being able to be in the
next paramount movie right okay so that
i think is the thing that's the impetus
for the other yeah but you're 100 right
in terms of like
the industry can't withhold anything
from him him specifically and i didn't
even just mean financially i mean
opportunity wise like he's not 100
millionaire off of movies or tv shows
that you wrote for him right he wrote
one himself and then he puts out his own
stand up and like opportunity wise he's
i think yeah but that makes a lot of
sense emotional cost and he's a
sensitive and i don't mean that in a
negative way he's a dude that's like
empathetic and like a human he's a very
thoughtful guy all right guys we're
gonna take a break from this exclusive
patreon clip that you can find at
patreon.com flagrant2 because i got to
tell you about the best boner pills in
the business and it's blue chew i'm
telling you right now there's no reason
you shouldn't be ready for action at any
point in time you got a side chick you
got a main chick you got a wife you got
an ex-wife it doesn't matter who it is
you should be ready to go and blow backs
out and you're gonna do that with the
blue chew and you know what else you're
gonna do you're gonna do it for free all
you gotta do is pay five dollars
shipping when you go to bluechew.com
okay use the promo code andrew you're
gonna get it for free just pay the five
dollar shipping the best dick you ever
had in your life these ladies deserve it
ladies if you're watching right now you
deserve it okay get your man on it asap
bluetooth.com promo code andrew now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
but yo this is actually i think this is
good like if we go make fun of everybody
if we're really going to do that thing
where we sit here and we go we make fun
of everybody yeah we can't just make fun
of the people that can't do something
for us yeah and then the people that can
do something for us we're like oh we got
to be polite everybody got to get these
jokes bro
yeah i hate saying you can't punch down
but i also hate not punching up
yeah like if you said we we're like yo
[ __ ] that punching down you can't punch
down [ __ ] but then if you're scared to
punch up you ain't [ __ ] either it was
funny that the last joke about the
punches down i think i was talking to
mark about this this was like maybe last
week i think i was talking to you about
this but i was like with the punching
down thing and i was like was it you or
maybe somebody else but like
i i had thought about the same thing
like i don't like the concept of
punching down because you make me you're
basically like i think less of everyone
yeah like you can't remember when we
were dealing with like some notes
process they're like
i think you said that he had this exact
conversation yeah okay we have said it
here okay yeah i always hate that
because it's like no you're placing them
beneath you i don't see it that way i
see me punching somebody that's equal to
me you decide they're beneath you that
reflects your own bias and it also
creates a social hierarchy yeah social
oppressions yeah
who's below what but look they're gonna
take it on the chin i'm gonna [ __ ]
take them everybody's gonna take it on
chin i think once you start to realize
that and feel that there's like a safety
and security built out there right and
maybe that's the shitty thing about like
being able to yank a joke out of a
special
it's like you're just like oh you see
this joke he made about asians it's like
were you listening to the joke you made
about the puerto ricans five minutes
before and the joke you made about the
jews seven minutes after like once you
understand the context not of the joke
itself the joke itself could be hateful
yeah but the context of the whole piece
yeah you're like oh okay i get what
we're doing here yeah and and that's why
roasts
nobody cares about
right because you walk into the rose
going we're gonna be hurtful for fun
yeah yeah yeah
the comedy special you walk in going
this is just gonna be a great old time
we're gonna laugh yeah so maybe we
should like start
the like disclaimer or like call the
special roast for fun or like just
[ __ ] when you walk in this is the
deal yeah everybody gets these i do that
at the top of every show i try to like
i'll say like we all laugh at [ __ ] up
jokes like we need this like we're all
gonna laugh at [ __ ] up things that's
the best yeah i think that's part of the
reason why
hey
i'm
i'm just trying to make you guys laugh
i'm not trying to hurt anyone's feelings
i am trying to make a point in terms of
like uh political statements yeah i'm
not trying to do it at the expense of
other people so if you feel that i am
you've misinterpreted me and
he probably feels a better job
that i typically think is [ __ ] but i
believe this one where he was like if
you listen to everything i've said on
every special about trans people i do
know i'm not complaining about trans
people or something he said i'm
complaining about white people and if
you think about all this [ __ ] he's
saying it's like oh i see what he means
with like the entitlement the white
entitlement that comes from
the white trans people who tend to be
complaining who tend to get heard the
most etc it's like i actually believe
that when he says this is about white
people
and not trans people and i think that
he's using trans people as an example or
gay people as an example
of
what black people can't do yes
right so he's just juxtaposing the black
experience in this other oppressed
groups experience and going yo why can't
we get [ __ ] out of here like
this and he said that i'm not
transphobic i'm jealous yeah how
effective your movement has been now
we're stuck here yeah yeah yeah yeah how
did you guys already get ahead of us
now do you believe that that is the
sentiment or do you think that that is
convenient logic to
probably a little bit of both maybe it
probably starts off a certain way and
then as you get hatred as a human being
would as people start telling you your
piece of [ __ ] you're like you know what
[ __ ] them and then you also start using
their rules against them yeah it's like
it's like they're like
that's the g like he's a master and i
mean this in the best possible way like
manipulator and as a comedian you do
have to manipulate the emotions of an
audience right even to induce laughter
but like that was masterful it's like oh
you set the rules and don't punch down
i'm going to convince you we're below
y'all
you better not bully me yeah you see
what you did to your own
you got your own offer themselves from
bullying right
he's like hey this is a feminist is hey
you just uh
want women to be equal and you wouldn't
allow the black feminist to speak at
whatever movement or whatever
so it's like
it's like even for a movement that's
about women you're still putting black
women below and i think he added that
point so he can make his final point
it was cool man like look i you know
that there's always going to be reaction
to a chappelle special
which is
uh well i didn't i didn't laugh as much
as i thought i would laugh or something
like that like that seems to be like a
lot of the reaction i think al you
brought up a really good point before
which is basically you're just comparing
it to other chappelle specials yeah and
and you brought up the
the drake uh analogy say that i thought
this was really poignant so um
let's certify little boy people are
saying this is
not one of drake's best albums yeah
because they're comparing it to drake's
other albums and it's like
your best work is going to come in the
beginning because it's like
a lifetime of thoughts that you want to
get out yeah and now you're having like
two years to put together especially but
at the same time it's quality of work
it's still so
beyond everyone else yeah it's still
good
would it be
would drake's album be the best
the baby album ever yes yeah you know
what i'm saying like if you were if if
the baby put out drake's [ __ ] right here
you'd be like oh my god this is the most
amazing one so he is competing with
himself in that regard so
even more so with comedy yeah who has it
for 20 years chris rock's last special
was his worst special tambourine had
some beautiful moments slow as [ __ ] the
first half hour who is still funny
billboard is the one guy i can think of
he's been doing it 20 years yeah and
he's still so strong but even then i
think it's a fame thing where you're so
famous you're just performing for your
[ __ ] like sycophants or whatever your
fanatics and they're gonna laugh at
everything so you don't necessarily
get to
cone and craft and whatever and it's
this superstar level where it's like
that's not sustainable for most comics
yeah you always hit a plateau and he
doesn't seem like obviously i can't tell
but it doesn't seem like he's performing
for his fans
like he it seems like he's hey i'm going
up there for myself and this is the [ __ ]
i want to get off like this this is [ __ ]
that's bothering me so i'm gonna talk
about it even if you dislike the fact
that i'm talking about trends in the
last three specials it's like this [ __ ]
still bothers me so i'm talking about
that yeah i respect that that's more
artistic to me than like oh let me just
focus on the big political things that
are going on at the moment yeah like
talk about the [ __ ] you care about yeah
that's the weird thing with chappelle as
far as like performing for his fans i
feel like if you're a comedy fan you're
probably a chappelle fan
you know what i mean yeah like it's not
really like music where you're like oh i
don't listen to that i only like this i
only like that like yeah most people
that are fans or like comedy nerds
they're like oh yeah i'll go watch a
pill yeah you know what i mean like he's
legendary and it was good to see him
doing comedy again yeah yeah unforgiving
and all that other [ __ ] i was like
yeah yep first half first half was jokes
i do think it's probably harder though
for him
to
get this same
type of like laughs per minute into
jokes
that he might have had previously in his
career simply because he's getting a
much bigger reaction off of
less funny jokes by proxy of his fame
like that that's just like so it's not
even his fault it's like where maybe he
was younger he would be like tag tag tag
another misdirect another misdirect keep
building keep building and like now he's
getting huge explosion off of premise
yeah you know punchline and i think that
that is the nature of fame
and
maybe that's why he's gone and like put
time into developing these stories
right because that's something that
doesn't change no matter who's watching
right right it's like i'm going to build
out this other thing i'm already getting
this huge pop off of this one idea that
maybe 10 years ago i'd have to drive a
bunch more punch lines in and really do
it but i can execute the exact point i
want to get the intended reaction way
quicker
let me develop these stories and make
these stories have these crazy arcs and
like beautiful things that's something i
can actually do despite how much the
fans love me appreciate me etc and
in my opinion i feel like that's a
bigger flex because
i see it with you guys it's like
uh you're able to stretch out a sword
and fit in jokes whenever you feel like
you fit in little uh pops yeah when you
feel and you can go like a cheat pop or
i was like oh no i give you a pointed
box and so when you get when you're
operating on that level um i think it's
harder for him to pick how long can i
get this story
and still keep you engaged yeah
[Music]
like no no i want to
send a message between these jokes and
that to me is like it's harder yeah yeah
yeah so when you're operating that level
it's like i'm not going to knock what
he's doing because i think he's doing it
so what do you say to the person that's
not familiar with chappelle's early work
but
sees chappelle and and assumes that this
is the greatest comic alive because
that's what they're hearing all the time
right but they just enter
this stage of his career is it similar
to
what i probably went through with carlin
where like i was told he's the greatest
and then i watched the later work and
i'm like man this guy's really smart and
he's saying like really thoughtful
[ __ ] things but like i'm not i'm not
laughing dying laughing but i recognize
he's a really smart guy and i recognize
everything great writer the the writing
is great the observations are really
brilliant but like i'm not dying
laughter the same way i'm dying from
watching david tell yeah or or watching
eddie murphy christopher
what do you say
to somebody
because it's hard for me because i'm as
a comic like it's hard for me to remove
it but what do you say to that person
like if my girl watches or something
like that i feel like with most art like
music or even even food it's like you
have to
uh
you get in on the easy stuff and then
once you realize that that stuff is easy
you appreciate the hardest
so it's like for somebody who just gets
into chicago now i'm going to tell them
no go back
start from the beginning because you
can't appreciate now unless you go back
early the other tricky thing about
everything art sports whatever it always
moves forward
very few things age well if you go watch
wilt chamberlain highlights right now
you'd be like this is the [ __ ] guy
this is the guy we're talking about shaq
would body this [ __ ] anywhere
that's just the nature of how could
these guys push everything forward jay-z
said it to lil wayne and uh the carter
he said go yo go farther go further go
harder is that not what we came if not
then why bother that's it
there chappelle pushed the envelope so
the next great guy can push it further
and chappelle got there because rock and
pryor and whoever else right they all
pushed it further you watch pryor now
it's funny it's not changing the world
but you don't realize comedy wasn't like
that until him but what are you saying
to the fan that's catching the end of
the journey not the beginning and their
reaction to the end
uh is based on a a wealth of knowledge
or lack thereof
of chappelle right like yeah you've only
seen maybe two specials and you're like
everybody keep telling me is the
funniest guy that's alive but i'm not
laughing as much as
i would just tell them to start from the
beginning and know that they might not
get it because it just always evolves in
the same way your dad tells you uh bill
russell is the greatest
basketball player of all time because he
changed the way defense was played yeah
and if you watch bill russell you'd be
like all right
that's that's the way the world moves
like i'm not my eyes aren't as developed
watching comedy as your guys yeah yeah
so it's like maybe cheaper jokes might
be funnier to me than they are
yeah you're like
i don't think that chappelle's early
stuff was cheap no that's right yeah the
way he did comedy was like oh i know the
best way to laugh
and it's like even though i'm still
making uh smart observations like the
laughs are quicker
so it's like you know he didn't what he
does a long story
what he does with the trans story level
of difficulty even though i [ __ ] love
killing them softly maybe my favorite
special the level of difficulty in the
trans story is higher than anything and
killing themselves yeah but to me the
trans story wasn't great because it was
funny it was just a beautiful
yeah all you would have been like he's
if you didn't story
such an amazing storyteller i mean this
sincerely and i knew going into it i've
said this my as long as you've known me
i've said he is the greatest public
speaker alive okay but the last time he
put out a public announcement get like
this
shitty story
shitty story no i swear was good
three-card monty was a good story no
he's talking about george floyd
yeah
should he just go out on youtube or
whatever yeah
if it was called a stand-up piece i
guess but like in terms of actual just
storytelling like i looked at that story
like i was watching the moth i don't
know if you guys remember that
but i was watching the moth and i was
like oh this is the greatest piece
that's ever been set on the moth like
this is i can watch that no matter what
it was so brilliant
i remove it from any category i just go
here is content to watch it so it could
be a ted talk [ __ ] amazing like it
didn't matter what it was it was just so
great
i guess i'm just trying to understand
like the new eyes like if
someone doesn't really know chappelle
that much like and then they start
watching a special and they don't laugh
as much what do what do i say to them do
i go
i don't know what do you think mark i
mean comedy is unique because you're not
only consuming the art in like it's
fundamental level you're consuming the
person as well whereas like with music
you're kind of just you can can just
consume like oh there's a song i heard
but like with comedy it's so intrinsic
to the person that's saying it that it
kind of requires having context of that
person
insofar as they require that you know
them and chappelle is so intimate when
he speaks it's like especially at this
stage in his career it's like yeah you
are kind of required to know him as a
person to really truly appreciate what
he's doing at this point his early stuff
you didn't need to know him and he knew
that because he was unknown so are they
wrong
to say
that it isn't as
joke dense or funny
as other comedians that they're familiar
with i don't think it's wrong like if if
my girl says that to me i can't go
you're wrong i'm not in an objective
sense but if you judge him and say he's
not as good as a comic holistically than
other comics i think it's just a hasty
judgment that i think i think that the
knee-jerk reaction is often like it was
really it was like really interesting i
just didn't laugh that much with this
stuff and
and and what i try to tell people i'm
like
i i don't i did this with i think
patrice put out mr p yeah and it was an
audio album and i was sitting in a car
with a friend and he was watching it or
he was listening to it we're just
listening together and he like really
wasn't laughing and then i was and i
told him before i was like this is the
greatest ever yeah and i realized i
might have not even laughed that much
but i was just so in love with the times
sure yeah but that's not the point i'm
trying i was just so in love with the
guy
and his
viewpoints and his thought process and
how he creates a joke and where he
creates mr x because you know him
because i know him and this new guy is
like yeah he had some really good ideas
and there were some funny moments i
laughed
but it was that moment i was like oh
[ __ ] have i been
mesmerized him does somebody have to
like uh
have i been hypnotized did somebody have
to shake me out of it no it's not
hypnosis it's just what
it's a little bit but but at the same
time it is art though because like
drake's early albums we love him because
he just put out bangers he's like how
can i put a bunch of bangers on one
album now he's focused on like yo i'm
gonna tell you about just a story about
some girl i used to [ __ ] and how she
wanted money and she like that like here
it is she's doing it more for him here
it is no no you just hit it you just hit
it
it is it is it is this
remember when nobody knew you and you
had to go on stage you had to prove
yourself every time you had to prove
yourself every time so of course
in that stage of your career the jokes
are going to be crafted in a way that if
someone's experiencing you for the first
time they're going to enjoy it the most
it doesn't necessarily mean that they're
the funniest but the jokes are going to
speak to things greater than just maybe
your experience they're complete and
exactly right so yeah you're going to be
i got to prove it every 10 seconds
otherwise they might not realize i'm
funny i got it every time bang bang bang
bang it's specifically crafted to the
person who doesn't know you yeah as you
develop the specials are specifically
crafted to the people that do because
oftentimes that is more interesting
so the people that really love you they
want to know about your experience what
the [ __ ] you've been through like when
richard pryor let himself on fire we're
like fam tell us why you were on fire
and you've also evolved as a person and
you're aware of your prior body of work
and like comment like comedians careers
are holistic in that way like game of
thrones like someone watches season five
and they're like i didn't like it it's
like yeah you joined
at the middle of the show what up people
you just watched a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com
flagrant2 all right peace